Speaker 1: We have to talk about books.
I like books.
I like reading and I say more books to the
better.
As a general rule doesn't mean every book
is appropriate for every setting or every
situation.
OK, we've talked about that before, but the
real question I have is, according to these
right wingers, is banning books good or bad.
And you might be saying, Well, David, no,
it's obviously good or it's obviously bad,
but it's really not so clear because we see
both perspectives from this modern American
book burning contingent that exists in the
right.
As I talk to you about not that long ago,
book banned efforts have hit their highest
levels and at least 20 years.
And it's the right, not the left, that's doing.
As we looked at this article must have been
what is this article even from about a month
ago?
We look we did the story a couple of weeks
ago, three three weeks ago or so that book
band efforts led by the American right wing
are at their highest level in 20 years now.
What we mean by book bands differs in different
situations.
In some cases, what we're talking about is
a movement by the right to ban a book from
being used in school.
Sometimes it's novels.
Sometimes it's certain history books, etc.
They're not necessarily calling for the books
to not be published or for the books to be
against the law.
But they certainly want to cancel a teacher's
ability to say, Here's a book that I want
to teach from.
They don't want to give teachers that opportunity.
In other cases, it's confusion about what
it even means, and we're going to get to that
in a moment.
But we know that the efforts to ban books
are at multi-decade highs led by the American
right wing, so they must be in favor of the
book bands, right?
Well, apparently not, because remember the
Dr. Seuss situation?
This was now about a year ago.
It's actually hard to believe it's been a
year, but it has been a year where the publisher
of Dr. Seuss Books said, Hey, you know what?
Some of these books.
This is our review.
We're a private business.
We can make the decisions that are right for
us.
We believe that some of these Dr. Seuss books,
they have elements that are not really sensitive
to modern cultural sensitivities.
We're a private business.
We're a publisher, and we think it's not good
for business to keep publishing some of these.
So we're not going to keep printing more copies.
We're not burning the books.
We're not saying the books should be against
the law.
We're not saying people can't read them.
We just think continuing to print these particular
books is no longer in line with what's best
for us.
And the right went crazy, saying, Oh my God,
the the left is banning the books.
They're canceling Dr. Seuss.
It's terrible.
Always allow the books everywhere, everywhere,
everywhere.
Oh, OK.
So they're against, I guess, limitations on
books.
Except now, as we talked about yesterday.
And as we've been talking about for several
months, they seem fine banning books when
it's books that they don't like, when it's
history books that tell the real story.
As far as we know at this time of slavery,
of racial discrimination, of all sorts of
different aspects of history.
All of a sudden, the very same right wingers
who were saying they're canceling Dr. Seuss,
they say, We got to get these books the hell
out of here.
We now are learning about this new effort
in Florida to reject math textbooks because
they contain so-called critical race theory.
Although Ron DeSantis and other Floridians
have not been able to provide a single substantive
example of where such critical race theory
exists.
So I guess the question of is banning books
good or bad?
The answer is, well, I guess it depends on
their mood.
I guess it depends on which books.
I guess it depends on who's doing it and why.
And it's a very similar phenomenon with protests.
If you're protesting police brutality, if
you're protesting in favor of Black Lives
Matter, if you're protesting in defense of
George Floyd.
Well, then these protests are dangerous to
law enforcement and we've got a back the blue
and they're all violent and looting and all
these different things.
But if you're protesting against Joe Biden
being the president and getting sworn in because
he was elected on January six, well, then
you're doing the right thing and you're being
treated very unfairly by everybody.
And what about back the blue?
Because they beat up some cops?
Oh no, no, no.
We don't care about that all of a sudden because
they were protesting against the certification
of the election.
Oh, so I guess it's not really so simple.
And the principle here is the one I've been
telling you about now for years, which is
they don't even really care about their own
stated principles.
They stake out apparent principles to justify
the end results that they already want.
If their principles all of a sudden would
point to actually Black Lives Matter can protest.
Actually, you shouldn't ban these books.
Then they change their principles because
their principles are no longer convenient
to their preexisting end goals.
And this is the theme we've been following
for years at this point in time.
I don't think this is going to stop anytime
soon, and in particular because they don't
really want to engage on what should climate
policy be, what should policy be on renewable
sources of energy?
What should the top tax rate be?
They can only engage completely.
Superficially, taxes are bad.
Green New Deal is bad because they are unwilling
or unable to engage substantively on those
issues.
They're going to keep pushing this stuff and
it works.
I don't want to be a broken record, but part
of why Glenn Youngkin won the Virginia gubernatorial
race is because this stuff works.
I will ban teaching of critical race theory.
Who's teaching it?
Well, it doesn't matter.
I will ban it.
Wow, I'm going to vote for this guy.
This stuff works.
Let me know your thoughts.
You can find me on Twitter at Packman.
The David Pakman Show is funded by you.
We really depend on you to produce this show.
We have a membership program at join Packman
dot com.
We do an extra show every day for the people
that sign up there.
We've got this show you're listening to.
We're watching now, but then we do another
show for our members.
We also offer commercial free audio and video
streams of the show every day, and we offer
them up to six hours before the show is released
to everybody else.
So there's some great perks to membership.
I would really love it if you signed up at
Join Pacman dot com and you can use the coupon
code Wow!
Twenty two to sign up at a discount.
I don't care at what price level you get involved
if you want to do the big boy, the Level four
yearly membership.
We welcome that if you want to get a monthly
membership with a discount code for under
two bucks a month, we welcome it.
We welcome all levels of support.
The point here is how many people can we get
involved?
That's the most important thing.
And you can sign up at join Pacman dot com